I want to start with congrats on this
movie I really dig this genre you know
the the murder mystery um and you're
always you know so good
um do you sort of what was it about this
project though because I know your
offered scripts what was it about this
project that said I want to do this
well Fox Searchlight came to me and it
was cut we have a relationship and so
they they just basically
offered it and said sir she was doing it
and it was kind of a no-brainer I know
that you like to prepare for each of
your roles
um how did you actually get ready for
this one especially with the accent
yeah the accent was intimidating I'd
done it about 20 years 30 years I don't
know a long time ago in theater twice
with uh Mike Lee play in the dumb waiter
and so I but I never done it on film so
I had two dialect coaches I had Martin
Friedman
tapes and vowel sounds for me and then
Eddie Marsden taped my lines I think and
a few other people what is it like
calling people like that and being like
or is it a text message being like hey I
need you to do me a favor yeah it's a
little bit of both you know hopefully I
can return the favor someday yeah
exactly
um one of the things that I found
amazing is that like listen coven sucks
it's the worst The only positive was you
got to film at locations that you would
have never got to film at if they'd
actually covet hadn't happened so what
was it like actually getting to film
with the Old Vic and these amazing
theaters which you would have never been
able to do it was amazing it was amazing
and I think probably cheaper for the
production and and extremely possible
you know
um
we had the the Savoy
was really great like The Shining you
know it was spooky and then the Old Vic
yeah which is in a few other places that
were just uh it was crazy it was a crazy
time yeah I love learning about like the
behind the scenes the making of movies
um and Joe's um what do you think would
surprise people to learn about the
making of This film well we had a
two-week rehearsal period which is kind
of unheard of with film these days
um
that was cool you know
um
you know it was again it was
the
the
you know the testing the covid testing
is what's gotten the film industry
through this time
um because if you test often you can
catch it before it spreads or someone's
shedding and so it's like
that that's probably saved the film
business along the testing system yeah I
know a lot of people that work in movies
and TV and I applaud the film industry
for for the testing it's the only reason
the business is still you know going
yeah yeah absolutely so uh listen you've
done so much awesome work if someone has
actually never seen anything you've done
before what is the first thing you want
them watching and why oh gosh
um I don't
I kind of want to just throw a random
like Don Verdine at them or something
sure
no I mean listen they're speaking about
our city yeah listen there's a lot of um
a lot of valid choices on your resume my
last thing for you I'm a huge Matthew
Vaughn fan oh yeah and I definitely want
to know what you can say about working
on Argyle and what that what it was like
working with him
it was great he's um
he's really a smart guy and he pays
attention to detail
he's really something I mean he's kind
of a genius and
we uh we had a great time
um it's you know it's like a romance spy
kind of thing with some comment with a
lot of Comedy but um it's great we it's
a really cool script really cool film
I've heard a little bit about it and
also he put together just like this film
he put together a hell of a cast yeah
absolutely yeah oriented to both Sam
Jacks and Brian Cranston Catherine
O'Hara
me and Bryce yeah listen they're gonna
throw me out I'm just gonna say it's
always a pleasure to see you I wish you
a brother thank you later thanks brother